no on a screen I'm brain again
description Winston's got the defensive
assignment called with the bounce this
game turns an ankle and the shot by
precision Simmons back to get away let's
put this over for this show is going
feed detonates on Westbrook and stares
him down Russell knows a thing or two
about going with that kind of violent
force to the back whistle and a foul
gonna go against the 76ers and indeed
let Russ know that he just yakked one on
him with the staredown remember in the
first meeting a triple overtime win
tomorrow a deadline he was in Indiana
getting ready for their game warming up
they pulled them off the court
Brown getting the crowd fired up we'll
be back with more with Asia but we
return suffix 37 it's Thomas fakes whips
a pass right to the hands of Middleton
[Applause]
as Middleton loved it
perfectly one of the more popular
players in the league started on the
alters teams with the Statue of Liberty
worn again has done a terrific job just
harassing see Jamie Cullum Napier has to
let it fly the shot clock winding down
in Lillard somehow in traffic elevating
and slamming on the follow
he came over everybody there's the
step-back hundred ala move just couldn't
get the finish no change look at that oh
right there that one if that will been
on
[Applause]
put him on the deck and then he
hesitated
take a look now me to have this damn
town wolf Johnson
too much sauce
Philadelphia players and it goes these
bounces legs look at that it goes
through topless legs what ha now after
the move we saw hard to do last night
with the 10-second pause after making
somebody tall and wait for the three I
like this one too
behind his back counts second chance on
the to dance left wide open
[Applause]
Jr has gone ballistic rough here
pounding it on the other side of the
floor the reason a reason for use hire
the triggerman
Drex plain little defense here behind
[ __ ] Louisa telling them I'm calling you
on the flip phone after the game ha ha
here we go rockets down three Ariza
they're out of turn
goes to Johnson back to Ariza they don't
fail
[Applause]
rebound gathered by Ziller here is the
tip into the front
plus the foul
some doubts
Brian used to like to say if you're
working out in June you're too late if
you're backpedaling against us at the
Copa you're too late
LeBron sees a crowd he turns the corner
and just bullets in a powerful tomahawk
slam jam LeBron James just dancing but
take a look at the broad barrel of him
well when he turned that corner any
players know players know who could jump
who can't jump LeBron has done this
enough
are working on rivers steps back
[Applause]
here is well that's why millennium MVP
candidate gives him a little step back
save hard when it counts it's bloody
flippers have really done a good he's
been waiting for that all game long
point one on the shot clock no Simmons
long with Rennick in the backcourt guys
got it now in eighth in the middle it's
got a mismatch that he caught late
throws it down in the face of Paul
Millsap well you can see the emphatic
finish over Millsaps
[Applause]
[ __ ] the [ __ ] wasn't on this dock
but this circuit I got playing against
are you saying Mariana vyx knew what he
was doing in no okay because you don't
see a steady diet about that I was
pretty
it's the loudest clipper fans who cheer
for their team tonight that worked
pretty funny we think about this Anthony
Davis is 7 feet tall and he can't even
gentle knock the ball out of Mariana
victims
[Music]
[Applause]
lutely Johnson now you've got Chris Paul
that is not right I mean that's
something you would see on the Rucker
League and if your zoo box if someone
else got to take Chris Paul off the air
right here this is the harm that a right
Falls done for the night serious doubt
of their bonds oh yeah
LeBron again spelling out his lookouts
then keep isolating Belinelli and the
bride is having a field day going to the
hoop he'll help no coming no chance no
chance would help today yellow and a
Hammond down the question is the misses
the second six point game Crockett on
the push
major rejection dragons thought he was
hit on the arlen bead but gorn's going
hard and yeah i tell you what a heckuva
that's a heck of a block but by bicycle
minnesota trying to get back in the
series hard defended by gypsum gotta put
him on the floor like he did Wesley
Johnson
[Music]
Martin asketh oh [ __ ] up and it's a
hairball great defense by Gibson
ten-second if we shut off the game clock
Engels pothead yes
and again Joe Engels right after the
dream right in the face of
we've gone here because we met leg
injury to only a sixth game back where
we just went down
since up out of our the cook suffix with
67 points with 645 remaining tatum
drives down that throws it down Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
Jason Tatum has electrified the crowd
and the Celtics back will enjoy damaged
engine with indeed and then beat is
right with a look at the teeth look at
their students by Joella beam against
the Class D table and it's gonna fuel a
great rivalry between these two great
organizations to them they must be
graded
[Applause]
unlimited range why isn't someone
crowding him making foot on the floor
[Applause]
[Music]
offensive player who just can't defend
them and Westbrook the game finishes at
the rim
he's rockabyebaby he's putting that baby
to sleep all denials defensively by the
Thunder Beverly sensing that very
aggressive defense
[Applause]
this is an aberration what is preventing
him from running putty
I didn't touch anything and it favors
the offense for the cross handle on the
honest I believe it will prevails one
more time do a lot of guys in on that
giving help well done defensive hands
okay so there's your poster tonight
without a charge going to be careful
here
gun shoe right now trying to play at the
defensive end got blown by back yes Jim
yeah and flex on him jaylen Brown
spectacular play by Brown over the Greek
now watch as he goes you got to see it
right here everything is fine until he
faced him